keep it going for kippy everybody
ah what the [ __ ] is this
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
i guess we want to thank spacex and
halliburton for donating this stool for
me
this is [ __ ] embarrassing i got it at
dxl i put it on your account
did you need a prescription for this
thing yeah you owe me the 50 buck copay
greg where's greg at is greg here
greg stop being a [ __ ] yeah what the
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] man i didn't
i'm sorry yeah i said he just yelled at
fully
[ __ ] right here jerk i'm sorry my
kind of guy you give it right back to me
greg
greg uh so your question uh do you
before you say before i say it do you do
this or does anyone in your family do
this
kid you went to school with how at what
age
craig definitely did this [ __ ] whatever
it is
this is definitely about greg in college
i think
all right this is do you or anyone in
your family pull their pants and
underwear all the way down to pee
that's got greg written all over and i
ain't gonna lie
that's a real great move right there
i mean though also when i saw the
question i'm like if he's doing this now
like we have to put a [ __ ] stop today
can we catch him out front just with his
[ __ ] pants by his ankles
i gotta go tinkies
[Laughter]
greg is that your wife or your
girlfriend
what's that do you guys live together
wow great
well well welcome to are you garbage
after dark ladies and gentlemen
that's a tough look you'll revert back
to it
i think we should find our own place
do you still share a netflix password
oh man
kevin's dad pulled that move about eight
years ago
he's here tonight dad what's up everyone
we're moving back in that's why don't
you guys live together anymore
i mean i have to ask i'm sorry
we assume that yeah
i didn't think it was because you both
bought your own house
you have got you have dyed red hair miss
we are assuming it's garbage we just we
decided to diversify our real estate
portfolio
and i didn't get my security deposit
back so
what so what happened
yo turn the lights down for this one
god damn chubbing up over here
where you got okay all right i have i
have family here i can't be asking about
threesomes in the crowd
see my uncle joe after hey nice to see
you yeah how about that redhead in the
second row huh uncle joe's in the back
like keep going
give greg and his girlfriend a nice big
round of applause
greg that didn't embarrass you you okay
all right he don't give a [ __ ] as long
as
he's like i don't care where i live
and greg to answer your question
unless you're nine years old that's
garbage
yeah if you were at a baseball game and
you walked into a urinal at [ __ ] nice
first of all wait nine is a little too
old for that to be honest with you
i was smoking six at nine
i can't be walking and pulling my
[ __ ] underoos down to take a pee
one more time for greg and his
girlfriend give a nice big round
thank you buddy and your hair's
beautiful by the way i was just